so I asked what is your wake-up call
what is enslaving you what is
controlling your thoughts is it the
television set feeding your mind images
of what life should be is it the
internet drawing you in and controlling
your time is it drugs or alcohol numbing
your brain and diminishing your desires
or is it weakness a lack of discipline
that prevents you from accomplishing
what you want to accomplish and I'm not
saying that you have to rebel I'm not
saying that there aren't things in life
that we just have to do there are but
what I am saying is ask questions and
don't believe everything that you're
told and don't follow the path just
because it's there don't get in line
just because other people are get up and
wake up and be conscious of what is
creeping into your mind what's getting
in there
what are you letting in there what is
forcing itself in there and what does it
want you to do
you have only one life so don't waste it
being controlled by someone else that's
one of those things it's it's everywhere
like you can easily be controlled by
stuff like a big one is I hate hate to
harp on parents but like your parents so
nobody's perfect right so all your
imperfections or a lot of your
imperfections will be passed on to your
kids just because you don't know any
better like that mrs. song lady like she
just believed it she didn't know any
better
mm-hm and so you can end up passing
these things down like certain
traditions or you know just
methodologies of raising kids that you
might hear otherwise but that's your
thing you know that you believed it it
crept in your mind because your parents
their parents you know and you don't
like how you say ask questions and you
don't ask question you're just like hey
that's how I was raised
you pass it on meanwhile you're doing
the wrong thing the whole time mm-hmm
that's what happens when you don't ask
questions that's what happens when you
don't ask questions you know that's what
happens when you believe authority all
the time yeah and hey this might come
across as some people are sitting there
saying wait a second Jaakko weren't you
in the military for 20 years you're damn
right I was yeah and there was a
definitely I was a rebellious kid and
when I was in the military I was always
everything that we did and why we did it
so and I think that's one of the things
that helped me get to a leadership
position and become a decent leader was
the fact that I didn't just take
everyone's word for it and say oh yeah
that's we're gonna do okay right no you
know what we're actually gonna change
the strategy we're gonna change the
tactics what I was taught isn't working
right now we're gonna do it differently
yeah they did that all the time yeah but
this is a broader scale this is a
broader scale this is life not just in
the book but life
general mm-hmm life in general like what
are you doing where are you getting your
direction from yeah who is who's got a
hold of your steering wheel yeah yeah
and that makes sure it's you that's got
a hold of your steering wheel
yeah and that's one of those things
where it's tough cuz you got to balance
it as well you know so if you're just
rolling around saying hey nothing's true
until I figure it out it's kind of like
you know you got to consider the
opportunity cost where some people you
got it you know you got to consider
their credibility and then you got to
kind of just go with it and and again
this is just kind of demonstrating like
there's a balance there yeah but just
like how you're saying if something if
it's not working and someone presents
you with some alternative don't just be
like hey I've done it this way so you
know
leave me alone type of thing you know
ask those questions and listen to them
you know chances are you might find a
little improve Matt didn't you learn
some stuff yeah or you might find out
that you've been sucked into a trap you
know do you don't want to be in no you
got it free your mind you got it free
your mind you got to get out of that box
out of that cage you know think of that
you know I meet people now and it's so
bizarre because because I've traveled a
lot and I've I've walked with a lot of
different kind of people mm-hmm you know
from all different walks of life and I
meet people sometimes and I think to
myself man this guy is pretty awesome
he's got all this you know on what this
person's goal is and sometimes I last
like a you know what do you want to do
or like what do you hey I'll meet some
kid or what you want to do and some
people say you know well I want to do
you know I I think they're I think
they're gonna come out with this giant
dream and they come out with like a
little mediocre idea
and I and I I haven't done this yet I've
talked to five people in the last six
months that I thought were gonna tell me
about their dream and that I was gonna
be like in shock and I was gonna be
impressed and say yeah that's what I'm
talking about brother go get it and
instead I had to bite my tongue because
they were telling me their dream but it
wasn't big enough mm-hmm it wasn't big
enough it wasn't it was too realistic
mm-hmm
you know yeah now you meet some people
sometimes and they tell me their dream
and I go man you ain't got a chance at
that you need to you need to tone that
down you need to get a grip
right these people are like you can
achieve anything you want no actually
you can't achieve anything you want if
you could achieve anything you want
you know everyone would be sitting on a
yacht or doing whatever big badass thing
that they want to do right kind of
depends away me but can't though but
yeah yeah it's true I mean can't that's
what I mean these get these people that
are like 'hey you can do whatever you
want no actually either's limitations to
that well all people are not created
equal mm-hmm some people are smarter
than other people some people are better
athletes than other people hey reality
now what can you hear the question isn't
that the question is what can you do
mm-hmm with your with what you've got
what can you do and I'd much rather I
love to hear people over shooting but
don't trap yourself in a box where
you're like well I'll be happy if I can
do this right and there's whole the
other part of this is it's sort of like
North Korea there's people that are
trapped in a paradigm in their head of
the world they think that the world is
this is this thing that they live in mmm
they think that the world is this small
this small place that the people that
they know right end of the
atmosphere that they live inside mm-hmm
and it's really really small and I think
to myself man you gots to get out and
I'll tell you part of this came when I
got out of the military because my whole
life you know the only guys I knew were
seals so I mean that's just who I knew
and so when I got out and I started
meeting other people and I especially
started working with big business and
started meeting really not just
successful in terms of financial people
but people that had really done
something mm-hm and I started realizing
that there was a whole nother level that
not a higher level but there's just
another world and yeah like in the SEAL
Teams oh well you know hey I did I did
my CEO opportunity to silverton
commander
you know you do these certain I did task
you know commander you do these things
and that's what you do mm-hmm
and it's awesome and that's a whole
world but there's other worlds I
remember telling one of my seal buddies
we were out surfing and it says after
I'd been out for like two years I had
this exact conversation with him I said
hey man like we were talking we were out
there surfing for an hour and for 58
minutes we're talking about the SEAL
team as the SEAL Teams the SEAL Teams
the SEAL Teams and the SEAL Teams and
then I said hey man the SEAL Teams is
awesome but just so you know there's
other things in the world and it's stuff
that I'm saying my mind was in North
Korea my mind was just SEAL team yeah
and I and I'll tell you what I'm glad it
was because it made my life very simple
and I still you know obviously I love
the SEAL Teams more than anything but
there are other worlds out there mm-hmm
and you can do other things in the world
and so now when I meet people in
different environments and different
jobs and in each little each little
environment that I poked my head into
because we work in different industries
all over of different you know
manufacturing and gas oil and and
financial and they're all their own
little
rolls and sometimes people are trapped
in those worlds and I just want to say
man free your mind free your mind and
see what else is out there yeah kind
like oh wait you and Tim were Tim
Kennedy we're talking about how you guys
you guys are an example of people who
have seen the really really bad parts of
the world and the really really good
parts of world cuz you guys travel all
over yeah and you live in San Diego
which is you know arguably one of the
one of the best places to live so you
have that expanded view meanwhile some
people they only go on vacation when
they travel so they have although a real
positive and in really nice view but
it's really narrow yeah or other people
who only lived in bad places just like
people who grow up in a real negative
household when they go out into the
world just their beginning view of the
world is negative yeah like money is
just so hard to come by because when
they grew up their parents are
complaining about the rent and bills are
piling up and all this stuff so that's
their attitude when they go out and then
then that's how they kind of take on the
world man I know this is kind of a
different thing same same concept same
subject but um I had a friend in in high
school and there's people I grew up on
quite small island in Hawaii so some
people straight up having their whole
life haven't been off of Kauai and no
less the mainland the mainland is this
fantasy world place where Disneyland is
and Hollywood and all this stuff so I
had a friend one of my good friends he
moved to the mainland but it was just
this small teeny tiny town just as small
as koi so I remember one time we what
state was the town it Colorado Colorado
is he to Pueblo he's called so I
remember we were just having a
conversation later and I was like hey
yeah let's let's go to Las Vegas a lot
of Hawaii people that'll Las Vegas and I
was like let's go to Las Vegas or
whatever I was like when do you do what
he do you rent a car he was like I would
never drive in Las Vegas I would never
drive in Las Vegas cuz it's too crazy
you know this freeways there's no
freeway I'm quiet
I don't want there there's a highway but
and he a grown adult so to speak um
can't even drive you know so that's like
an example that's how narrow his his
whole view
world this whole world and that extended
to his driving skill you know this was
just this so hectic on a freeway highway
Las Vegas even I don't even know how
crazy that is I mean that's not a crazy
place to drive really you know come here
to like I don't know is very rare so to
LA then hit the 405 north on a Thursday
afternoon yeah there's no doubt there's
so much out there and if you stay
comfortable in your world you can get
used to you can get comfortable starving
in North Korea yes that's what the scary
thing is that's the point that I think
I'm trying to make is don't be
comfortable because what you think is
awesome right now there could be so much
more you know if you can envision and
pay attention to what's going on in the
rest of the world mm-hmm and break out
of that paradigm that you're in mm-hm
and see that you can fly
mm-hmm you can fly around the world you
can do it you know don't get trapped and
for your mind yeah